we're going to take you to a live press
conference now between Israel's prime
minister and his British counterpart
fact that you came to Israel tells us a
lot I said to President Biden yesterday
that there's one thing more heartwarming
than standing with Israel it's standing
in Israel and the fact that you came
here to do that uh is a very strong
statement of support which we deeply
appreciate uh Chancellor Schultz who
also visited here called Kamas
uh the new Nazis he was right you fought
the Nazis 80 years ago uh resolutely uh
and the entire world supported your
action President Biden called Hamas
worse than Isis he's right too Hamas are
the new Nazis they're the new Isis and
we have to fight them together just as
the world the Civilized World United to
fight uh the Nazis and United to fight
Hamas it must together now stand with
Israel as we fight and defeat defeat
Kamas this is not merely our battle it's
the battle of the entire civilized world
it's the Battle of uh Israel it's a
battle of the moderate Arab countries
it's the Battle of uh Western
Civilization the battle of the Free
World the battle for the future we have
here two forces one is an Access of Evil
led by Iran through kisala Hamas and
others that want to bring back the
Middle East of the Middle Ages to an age
of bonded bondage and War and slavery
and Annihilation and the other force is
the forces of progress uh and Humanity
that want to push the Middle East into a
world of peace and prosperity we were on
the cusp of expanding that peace and
destroying that move was one of the
reasons why this action was taken we
have to resist it and we have to win
above all we have to win we have to
release the hostages you have Nationals
understand that I know you do that we
have their children babies
women uh elderly Holocaust Survivors and
your Nationals and we have to work
together in every way possible and we're
doing that to get them back I appreciate
the fact that you also sent some
military forces into the region we
discussed practical cooperation on many
fronts and I value that very much 80
years ago 80 years ago prime
minister the Civilized World stood with
you in your darkest hour this is our
darkest hour it's the world's darkest
hour we need to stand together and we
want to win and this is why I support I
value your support and the fact that
you're here we must win together that
means that this is a long war and we'll
need your continuous support continuous
support there'll be ups and downs
there'll be difficulties the people here
are united they're prepared to take the
necessary
action I've never seen the people of
Israel as United more united than they
are now but we need that Unity across
the board and continuous support as we
prosecute and win this just war against
the modern barbarians the worst monsters
on the planet thank you Richie for
coming
here well prime minister thank you for
your warm words and for welcoming me to
Israel I'm just sorry to be here in such
terrible circumstance ances in the last
two weeks this country has gone through
something that no country no people
should have to endure least of all
Israel which has lived through some of
the most awful scenes the Spectre of
violence and terrorism every day of its
existence and I want to share the Deep
condolences of the British people and
stress that we absolutely support
Israel's right to defend itself in line
with international law to go after Hamas
to take back hostages deter further in
incursions and to strengthen your
security for the long term now I know
that you are taking every precaution to
avoid harming civilians in direct
contrast to the terrorists of Hamas
which seek to put civilians in harms way
but I also want to thank you for the
support that your government has given
to the families of British Nationals
caught up in this horror including your
efforts to release the hostages secure
their release and I know that we will
continue to cooperate particularly with
regard to the British Nationals that are
involved can I also say that we have
seen the scenes over the past day that
have shocked all of us particularly at
the hospital and we mourn the loss of
every innocent life civilians of every
Faith every nationality who have been
killed and we also recognize that the
Palestinian people are victims of Hamas
too and that is why I welcome your
decision yesterday that you took to
ensure that Roots into Gaza will be
opened for humanitarian Aid to enter I'm
glad that you made that decision we will
support it we are increasing our Aid to
the region and we will look to get more
support to people as quickly as we can
uh the last thing for me to close on is
this you describe this as Israel's
Darkest Hour well then it's for me to
say I'm proud to stand here with you in
Israel's Darkest Hour as your friend we
will stand with you in solidarity we
will stand with your people and we also
want you to win
thank you thank you thank you very
much thank
you we must win together the message
there of Israel's primee Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu saying this means a
long War standing alongside his British
celt Rashi sunak he went on to thank the
UK saying we appreciate that you sent
military forces to the region he said
that the battle was one in which Israel
was fighting the new Nazis the new Isis
a battle he said of Western Civilization
against an axis that wants to take the
Middle East back to the Middle Ages for
his part Rishi
sunak offered his absolute support the
UK's absolute support for Israel's right
to defend itself in line with
international
law well let's bring in Alan fiser who's
live in Tel Aviv so Alan distilling that
solid support from the UK although he
did
mention in line with international law
but we did not hear any criticism of
some of the Israeli tactics that
International Israeli human rights
groups un experts are calling violations
of law in
Gaza and Benjamin Netanyahu know
those days are coming because you can
tell from his statement saying we will
need your continuous support and now I'm
paraphrasing I didn't get the exact
quote down but essentially there will be
dark days and difficult days ahead we
need your continuous support it's like
saying when we start to get criticism
for some of the things we do you can't
disappear uh Rishi sunak making it clear
that they support any action within
international law and yet no comment on
the the the decision by the Israelis to
shut off power to shut off water and to
stop food going into Gaza which of
course many people would regard as a
breach of international law he welcomed
the fact that they were going to let Aid
into Gaza there is the question too
about people who also hold British
passports who are trapped in Gaza and
can't get out and so that is an issue
that will have to be addressed very
quickly as well and as you rightly say
no question of of Rishi sunak calling
for a ceasefire a human Ian window to
allow Aid to be allowed into the country
instead expressing his support and
saying once again that the Palestinian
the Palestinian people are victims of
Hamas as much as the people in Israel
are as
well all right want to thank Alan fiser
for recapping what we just saw there
between the prime ministers of Britain
and Israel